so Roma is looking at Trump's Twitter
and it's not the worst idea my only
issue is if you've been on Twitter you
know how easy it is to get distracted
right Mama's gonna log on to investigate
Trump and the next thing you know he'll
be watching videos of dogs dancing to
Drake which by the way is a real thing
[Applause]
I've watched that three hundred times
good reason Daily Show's Trevor Noah
these special counsel Robert Muller this
week about investigating the president's
tweets Noah and his team are up for
three awards this year including
outstanding variety talk series it's the
comedian's first nomination in that
category since taking over the reins
from Jon Stewart in 2015 now the writers
in The Daily Show are out with a new
book inspired by President Trump's
tweets it is called the Donald J Trump
presidential Twitter library the book is
based on the show's successful pop-up
library that The Huffington Post
describes as the most impressive satire
of the current administration to date
that is something Trevor Noah
is here a television event good morning
my friend book is elegant yet hilarious
thank you it is one of the first
attempts we've seen to look at this
presidency almost through a historical
left-right say my question to you is do
you think this crazy moment we're in is
passing crazy or permanent crazy well I
think if you look at Donald Trump and
that's what helped us look at the tweets
in context you have to think of the man
and how consistent has been and one
thing that we've known about Donald
Trump is that like a star he burns
bright and he burns for much longer than
a human will expect him to burn and so
it always feels like the crazy is gonna
pass but this has been what people have
said for what the past three years if
they said it wouldn't go through to the
election people said it wouldn't go
beyond the election people said it
wouldn't go into his first year or a
second year and so we've come to realize
that this is the world we live in now
this is the world that we share with
Donald J Trump and as you see every
single day there's a new story to talk
about oftentimes sparked by his tweets
we get bombarded with these tweets what
do you see when you put them all
together in a book well you see that's
what's great about the book so we sat
down at the Daily Show and we said we
can't look at each tweet individually it
doesn't tell your story if you wake up
every morning and you look at a Trump
tree like Marco Rubio said you'll go
crazy and so tweets and context that
gives you it gives you a patent so it
gives you a patent on how Trump creates
the smallest benign things like how he
creates nicknames for his political
enemies it also tells you how much he
hates diet coke more than Hillary you'll
be surprised
more than Hillary Clinton or the Hillary
hates I know more than Hillary Clinton
and then and then what's really
interesting is looking at how he sees
the witch-hunt
how he sees the investigation against
him how he communicates with people who
work for him you see how the Jeff
Sessions tweet is not something that he
tweeted in isolation you start to notice
a trend and so when you put them into
categories you realize that not only is
he an interesting present but I would
say he's the most prolific Twitter user
we have seen in our lifetimes and the
interesting thing about the Twitter is
well it's been a perhaps effective use
of communication for him to speak
directly to his supporters what happened
yesterday in the tweet where he urged
Jeff sessions to end the investigation
as the New York Times put it today that
tweet crossed a line that mr. Trump has
never explicitly crossed until now right
that it may be in terms of obstruction
of justice where he most directly said
on a platform to his tens of millions of
followers essentially urging obstruction
of justice what's interesting though is
now we're going to engage in a
discussion about should versus would
that's going to be the next source
people say are you saying should as and
this is what I think you should do
versus what you must do you must scrap
the investigation and then also I think
it's interesting that Donald J Trump has
flipped the script on everybody he
showed us that the things most people
would do in private that get them busted
if you do them in public right it's
somehow better which is not how I've
ever lived my life I've never seen an
instance where doing something bad in
public
somehow lets you off the hook as a
comedian he gives you an enormous amount
of material yes he does an embarrassment
of riches how do you determine where the
lines are is anything off-limits yes
well I work of what the president says
you know unlike most III go this is the
presence of the United States I don't
say his hashtag not the present he is
and so I will give him the the respect
and the attention that he deserves and
so that's what the Twitter library book
is about it's us looking at the
president saying although many
presidents have used speeches and
written words to convey their ideas
Donald J Trump uses his tweets so we've
decided to acknowledge that in the book
and give you context for that there are
a host of people who say we are too
focused on the tweet as this
happening there is regulatory rollback
there are changes being made that have
real significant consequences on health
care the environment yes but nobody's
paying attention to that because the
tweets are so addictive right and I say
to those people don't have more than one
child because clearly you kind of focus
more than one thing at the center
because I think you can focus on can
focus on what the prison is saying and I
think you can also focus on what the
administration is doing I don't think
the two are mutually exclusive so the
idea that we can only look at one thing
at the same time is a ludicrous concept
to me I think if you give adequate time
I mean that's what you do on your show
every day but I give you a high-five
there because I do think you have to
cover them but as journalists we have to
remind ourselves that the original
reporting the investigative reporting
the storytelling that we do is just as
important if more important than ever
now right and that's that's what we look
at on our show as well we go like okay
that's why your eminence Emmy nominated
show no let's talk about it first time
first time outstanding variety show big
time it's really exciting and you know
what's funny is credit to the team that
made this happen and credit to John
Stewart who predicted that he said to me
hey it's not gonna happen your first
year not gonna happen your second year
but as you get into your third year it's
gonna happen and I said what if it
doesn't then he said oh then you're a
failure
thank you the Donald J Trump residential
Twitter library on sale now and the
daily show airs weeknights on Comedy
Central
teasing